because different infighting and each
other's throats the hatred that you have
against a Muslim in your heart the hick
malice you see a Christian walk by you
see a sequel by you'll speak to them
you'll hold the door for them if you see
a brother with a beard in the fold
bonanza
that can't be right
[Music]
I shall open
lady so high level things above
what then
Monica Muhammad way better care subhana
sisters and the offend hopeless is worth
doing well inshallah
first I wanna place a loss upon allah
tala the most merciful the most trust or
praise glory and gratitude belong to him
we are in California hundred an amazing
event we had the hijab debate and we're
having talks in different places
tackling different issues and
hamdulillah we came across the chef's in
a blessed insha'Allah it's an honor to
be amongst them and with chef Mufti when
I was supposed to meet him in New York
and Qatar Allah was talking about is so
profound because we was on the way to
see him in New York and some
miscommunication happened something like
using well or something was actually on
the way I was taught about he's not well
and we just did a u-turn and went to
another restaurant and it was told oh no
that wasn't the case but anyways it was
it was disappoint it was we really
wanted to see him and we came to
California jabs the bay and I'm sitting
there and you know my vision has been
good recently and I see somebody coming
too so I was just I got the clothes and
I was a believer and actually will it
sustained at the Masjid in the room and
and they told us ok this is a comment so
we did not we were then you know we had
to evacuate and get kicked out everyone
goes through this face well you just you
know you just gung-ho
oh yeah and then everyone and it give
label you look down on people now how
does someone deal with that because when
they come into this realm it's it's it
causes more damage they have and then
one thing that I don't see is like
sometimes I was certain brothers etc and
you know I think I'm around and I'm
thinking to myself what will you see
another believer and because you leave
him to be something else and the hatred
you have towards him and to the level
where if you saw in me an attack on the
street you're you're happy and it
doesn't make sense to me that was the
son of really like like this but then we
were around certain brothers and the
love that we see and what advice would
you give to youngsters who are going
through this phase and and I've seen a
lot of people they actually gone through
this face and
they come out they have a burnout and
they require what advice would you give
to those youngsters that are watching
and having this kind of mentality this
kind of thought process if you get what
I'm trying to say clear yeah I need as a
little continuation before they start I
don't want to hog the mic as we say huh
they're running from there but it's okay
they put it on me huh
at the end of the day at the end of the
day um it's very disheartening it makes
you sad but at the same time like I just
said it should make you happy because
it's a manifest manifestation of what is
mentioned they will continue to differ
except for those whom Allah has mercy so
you guys different in fighting and each
other's throats the hatred that you have
against a Muslim in your heart the hip
malice you see a Christian walk by you
see a Sikh walk by you'll speak to them
you'll hold the door for them if you see
a brother with a beard in the fall
vinnitsa that can't be right
even if he's doing something wrong but
that cannot be right that I have such a
stone face against a Muslim and I have a
smile when I see a polytheist of
mushnick and I speak to them and I'm
nice to them that doesn't make sense so
that's a very very long discussion most
of all with regards to the different
hours and the different groups and
scholars and translations and harshness
and that's a long long long discussions
my advice to the youngsters they get
caught up and swallowed in all of this
stuff there's a statement that some of
the scholars of Islam used to say you
read to and you're clear
well I'm Maggie oh yes the birdie wants
to fly but he still has bushy feathers
the birdie wants to soar and swoop down
but it's still in the nest and it
doesn't have long and straight feathers
yet you just yesterday you are Christian
yesterday you were smoking weed with
tattoos chasing girls now you're an
expert on I'll jump with ideal now
you're an expert on who's a Mook teddy
and whose ball and hose mobility where'd
you study yaki what are you studying
there's basically semester question did
you study anything formal just yesterday
you were this new you were then now
you're this grand master of him you need
to a nuclear what a mega Sh he wants to
soar like the Falcon swooped down and he
still has bushy feathers
yes that he was being fed worms and
anyone who studies birds of prey you
know how difficult it is to actually
have a successful hunt it's not like
it's on TV or a movie Falcons and eagles
they oftentimes starve it's not easy to
catch that rabbit or that rat in the
field it's great to the skill in
practice so just yesterday you were in
the nest
squeaking for worm and now you're trying
to soar down on other Muslims brothers
have been overseas the enemy Jazza
the memorizing Quran have Kira act Kira
at versions of recitation and you're
just yesterday war upon Allahu Alem
that's my advice is to look at your
feathers how long are your feathers what
color are your feathers baby owls don't
look nothing like adult hours they're
different colors let alone the nature of
their feathers so I'm Debbie rahim allah
tada
he quoted this about a amo hadith or a
student of hadith that was trying to you
know butt heads with some other people
who says you need to earn your clear
when I make your English
he wants to soar but he doesn't have
long feathers so yeah and if that enough
SiC know yourself no learning at your
place he may be a move teddy
monk in maybe maybe I'm a DV or your DV
it's possible but it's not for you to
say that because yesterday you were
hunting in the field like yeah and he's
teaching in Berkeley University here in
California so it's much qualified first
and foremost I thank both of you once
again just for coming here and sharing
your knowledge with us so the question
is now because this is a matter of
knowing the notes right no everyone
knows how to know the notes not everyone
knows how to distinguish the accounts of
have money from the real money and when
people do try and do that once again it
causes social division which doesn't
mess
we need to exist and I've made the point
that in America for example I looked at
the numbers
23% of Muslims are becoming apostates
according to Pew Research 20,000 laughs
which is a massive number and some of
the reason for that is because they see
internal conflict I'm not saying that
that conflict should never exist I'm
just saying that you know this is an
issue so can you give us a little bit
more information on who is qualified who
are qualified people to deal with this
matter of not just have D ABBA
all kinds of labeling in Islam yeah
smaller and Rahim in reality this
phenomenon that you were referring to
where people as soon as they begin it is
and as soon as they begin to become
religious they start to grow their beard
they start to shorten their throat and
so on they automatically think that they
are the greatest of scholars right as
the Ottoman they say the knowledge is of
hand spans the first hand spend you read
one book you think you're the most
knowledgeable person in the world the
last hand span UN do you actually find
out that you know nothing you actually
finished seeking knowledge you know that
you don't know that you know nothing and
so I believe that this phenomenon the
number one reason for it's spreading is
being impatient
out of turnip being impatient with
seeking knowledge you want to reach a
station that you have not matured for
yet you want to reach a station that you
are not qualified qualified for yet as
soon as you read one book two books you
end up thinking that you are gonna pass
gentlemen on this email and this scholar
and you're going to make this person
this is the most dangerous thing upon
its names not just for you
other Muslims to as the anima they said
the most dangerous thing is half a puppy
swam laughing same thing half a linguist
- slowly
half a mo hadith you're you could you
start giving photos and send someone in
the wrong direction and ended up
actually debate an atheist or debate
someone from while the DVS X and then
Muslims hear this debate and you don't
have the knowledge to debate him and
they hear that is there
but those people who are not qualified
to have that matured yet we do with
Salah right once again have crops and so
on and selling crops you have to have
that maturity you have to be ripe and
that's why some of the element they said
that you shouldn't lie books before the
age of 40 some of our automatic said you
should write books before the age of 40
because your mind isn't full fully
developed yet and that's why we see even
from amongst the Sahaba where some
companions would not speak in the
presence of other companions who are
more knowledgeable they would not speak
even though it's a hobby we would not
speak in the presence of someone who is
more knowledgeable and so dear brothers
and sisters I really want to emphasize
this concept that before you begin to
judge other scholars or other Amanda
this one's an innovator and this one is
wrong and this is the authentic hadith
this is the weak hadith this is a TV
opinion this is a logic opinion you have
to reach the level that these scholars
reach first so panel of a person came to
a mimetic and said you're placing your
motto the hadith that the buyer and
seller have the option have the option
to rescind the contract but you don't
act upon it
mmm medic he said I place that hadith in
my book so someone like you a fool Angra
person like you wouldn't come later and
say that you didn't know the hadith I
know the hadith but I have other
evidences why I didn't take the hadith
this is a phenomenon that really is
causing the destruction of Islam
subhanAllah some people say you know go
against the chef I mother he didn't have
the hadith he you know he didn't know
the evidence and person Imam Shafi is
same as someone came up to him and said
something similar to that
he said subhanAllah am i how do you
think I don't act upon the hadith you
see as soon love you see that belt of
the Christians around my waist you see
me go into a church coming out of a
church
of course I'm act upon the hadith but I
have other evidences that made me
realize that this is the correct hadith
not this one
like a madman telling me the he met
Jesus all the time in his book there
forgive me no hard this forgive me he
said this he mentions a hadith it could
be authentic and there's no I might upon
it he says there's another planet so
there's a weak hadith when I'm an island
it's well along
they act as scholars act upon it
subhanAllah even in the Jose me he said
that there is no hadith in holida Haram
except a chef a new ownership he said
that a muhammad all the hadith were
presented to him and ever
and he knew what to take him on not to
take what was shared and what was acted
upon what was strong what was weak so
how are we gonna come later on after
reading one book two books in English
and now we're this one's MOOC Ted that
no chef I was wrong
medic is wrong a lot goes wrong this is
the right answer this person's this this
is not the way this is not a way to
signal I just want us to finish on a
statement because what you said is very
true because and there is a feint a
statement which I don't know who was
from he said a scholar knows who's agile
because he was once one never knows who
the scholar was never won a llama and
it's such a profound statement and I
just want to stand that finish off with
this dollar bill because like I said
mostly that we have the pen to know if
it's fake or not but when the pen is
given to those who think they know it's
what is correct or not and they mark it
and say to a real not it's fake it
causes problems is wrong because he's
gonna be telling people oh this is fake
why because he doesn't have experience
and he's marked it wrong
I just once finished on that statement
genre and it's all good may Allah bless
you guys well lie it's been absolutely
amazing profound inshallah brothers who
are watching this inshallah they can
benefit from this inshallah and yeah may
Allah bless masala it's absolutely an
honor to have you guys a same here and
we always ask our youngsters this is
something in Salaam something that we do
to always refer to people of knowledge
always always because miss Gladys
happens because of yes I know me if we
hear somebody say me I us you're always
going to see this sugar future journals
yes yes inshallah yes definitely
disciple sorry yes inshallah and if the
other shells go yeah I'm waiting toy
inshallah do follow the workshops of 40
years the description box inshallah you
can follow them to next time
assalamualaikum warahmatullah better
here too